دمار كبير لحق بهذا المنزل منزل الشهيد
حسن قفيشه الذي فجره الاحتلال في الخليل
بعد اقتحام استمر لاكثر من خمس ساعات
خلاله جنود الاحتلال فرضوا طوقا امنيا
شاملا في هذه المنطقه واغلقوا كافه الطرق
المؤديه الى هذا المنزل واستمر جنود
الاحتلال في الحفر بالجدران الداخليه لهذا
المنزل لاكثر من خمس ساعات وقاموا بتفجيره
الشهيد حسن قفيشه الذي نفذ عمليه اطلاق
نار في الس 16 عشر من نوفمبر الماضي رفقه
الشهيدين عبد القادر ونصر الله القواسمي
الذين قام الاحتلال بهدم منازلهم قبل
حوالي ثلاثه اسابيع في مدينه الخليل قبل
ثلاثه اسابيع هدمت منازل الشهداء عبد
القادر ونصر الله القواسمي وهذه الليله
هدم منزل الشهيد حسن قفيشه الذين نفذوا
عمليه اطلاق نار عند حاجز النفق جنوبي
القدس في السادس عشر من نوفمبر الماضي هذه
العمليه ادت الى مقتل جندي اسرائيلي
واصابه سبعه جنود اخرين بجراح بهدم هذا
المنزل يصبح عدد المنازل التي هدمت في
الخليل في اقل من شهر ثلاثه منازل فيما
بقي منزلين مختارين بالهدم في بلده بني
نعيم شرق الخليل لاسيرين من عائله زيدا
تتهم قوات الاحتلال بتنفيذ عمليه رع نانا
في تل ابيب قبل حوالي شهر ادت الى مقتل
اسرائيليه واصابه 18 اخرين انتصر نصار
الجزيره الخليل